here we go ladies and gentlemen this is
a tweet from Wesley hunt let me slow
down here great dude by the way he says
tonight at the Timberline caucus as I
spoke on behalf of President Trump an
enraged man attempted to stop my speech
he shouted Trump was racist you know the
same Tire Trump we heard over and over
but on this day on of all days Martin
Luther King Day people of Iowa just like
President Trump Judge Me Not by the
color of my skin but by the content of
my character the anti-trump movement is
in full-blown meltdown so let me uh
let's uh play this is the smartest most
Gen M four minutes minut do we know what
yeah about a minute and a half in minute
and a half and this is from someone on
the disantis team they say he was a
disantis
supporter now I'm a military guy by
trade come from military family my dad's
retired colel my sister went to West
Point first in my family I went to West
Point my brother went to West Point
there are 60 years
the he rushes the court today today
today
[Music]
today to us about
[Applause]
[Music]
racist do this ontin Luther King wow
what did he say
[Music]
so so how do you know this guy is
connected to disantis I'll just say this
was a text I got he said a desanta
supporter he said how could you do this
on Martin Luther King Jr day or
something like that is like is that a is
that a white
guy no no that's not that's not no no
this guy right it's
it's I mean me and Sheamus had more
serious arguments than that I'm saying
yeah they went each I just I don't see
skin col is the guy is the guy who's
yelling at Wesley HT also a black man he
appears to be right I I can't you it's
hard it's hard to
tell but is that his point that Wesley
Hunt is betraying Martin Luther King or
whatever or something like this but how
who knows for supporting TR okay he said
something that bothered the audience but
we missed it it was a little bit before
he say how how D you he's racist or
something like that shout out to Martin
Luther King let's uphold his well I
think he's getting a lot of flack right
now I think the important thing to
recognize too
is there's a lot of people at history
people need to know the the truth about
and and if you don't really pay
attention uh you might just believe the
simple things of them a good a good
example is like Shay guara like that
dude was like a really bad guy but young
people just wear shirt all the time
because they don't pay attention that
being said Martin Lu King Jr had had
some great points but uh I'm not going
to sit here and try and adjudicate the
whole debate that's been going on but a
big thing happening right now is
criticism of MLK over a lot of stuff
that he was involved in I don't know I
don't know enough about it I know the
FBI knows about it since they were
spying on him and then uh recording his
private conversations with his
Mistresses and then playing it to his
wife when he was in jail trying to of
course get them divorced as of course a
court in t in Memphis actually found the
US government complicit in the
assassination of MLK well take a look at
this from uh on Twitter on X the the FBI
tweeted this MLK Day the FBI honors one
of the most prominent leaders of the
civil rights movement and reaffirms its
commitment to Dr King's Legacy of
fairness and equal justice for all
there's a community note that reads the
FBI engaged in surveillance of King
attempted to discredit him and used
manipulation tactics to influence him to
stop organizing King's family believed
the FBI was responsible for his death so
shout out to community not on X that
they believe there was an actual court
case in Memphis in 1999 that looked at
all the evidence
and a jury found the US government
complicit in the assassination of MLK
they paid a civil fee I think they they
W they won $100 but the one $100 was
just uh for the court proceedings to
kind of move forward I got I got some
bad news for you Alex Ron's actually
pulled ahead of Nikki by by a good
amount well we'll see what happens as
long as Nikki loses tonight I'll be
happy uh otherwise I I kind of really
don't care the idea of anyone losing to
Nikki Haley is just so depressing a poor
viic I I it even makes me sad to see
Chris Christie lose to Nikki it's just
like well there's only one there's only
one winner and that's whoever gets the
most so that's there's no everyone's a
loser except for djt at this rate the
the FBI first your last just don't want
to let this slip the FBI preot the
suicide note for MLK is that correct yep
yep and they were encouraging him to
take his own life when he was going
through a difficult time yep they sent
letters they sent letters saying you got
to off yourself you got to kill yourself
you're a horrible person because of so
and so sign FBI or what signed F no no
the FBI literally was running scops on
MLK where do I know this the FBI's own
files so the FBI has released these
files and they have like they're
available on the FBI website you and the
agents who did this were never held
accountable so this was the beginning
stages of the FBI under Jay Edgar Hoover
who also uh was a person who was
probably being extorted as well for the
dresses that he was wearing but but but
but that's the start of the FBI what are
they doing now RFK Jr was just asked
about the the
recently and he defended JFK
andapp of MLK wow yeah he's he's in said
he needed to do it yeah why which is
crazy he's he's in a tough spot he's
he's but why did he think there's
something strange happening to Father
don't know what's happening to RF Jr but
there has been a huge turnaround in his
in his in his kind of team that is very
kind of bewildering uh he was on
admittedly um and we found this out
through the documents but before the
documents came came out he said he was
on the Lolita Express which with Jeffrey
Epstein and his wife all the way back in
the early
1990s um and that's what he admitted to
his father was attorney general
overseeing the FBI's operations and so
he's being asked to defend his late
father right I suppose would be the
actually going on JFK Jr RFK Jr is being
asked to defend his father's actions he
must have signed off on this you'd have
to assume I mean I don't know but you'd
have to assume in some level his father
knew about what they were doing to MLK
and so RFK junr in a tough spot I mean
it's your it's your dad who met his own
untimely demise I mean obviously you
know tragically and horrifically so it's
like probably at the hands of the Intel
agencies ex they said it was Siran Siran
some Wild guy in a kitchen but fellas I
do have to bounce all right man I
celebrate a victory and uh appreciate
you hanging outs as you can see it was
very close we we we uh we're are wait we
are waiting hopefully the vake can come
by going to be here in a few minutes
according to a text that I've been
receiving a few minutes I don't want
false hope but 8 I think 8:15 was the
call time but we'll see we'll see
everything 815 was the call time yeah so
one minute ago he he's to V's credit
between the three candidates that are
behind Trump right now he significantly
spent less money and is probably
overperforming that his predictions were
early in the cycle and and and also
Nikki Haley's voters a lot of them
probably Democrats yep so you know I
don't even consider her vot to be actual
she not convincing anybody but
Democratic party to vote for Nikki
Hillary the also worked very hard um
hitting the ground game here more than I
think anyone else so and it's crazy you
know when Ronda Santos does an event and
he meets people the people that he meets
typically don't like him a v kind of his
charismatic and he has something called
Riz these video what's this video of the
guy guy in the wheelchair getting thrown
out of the disos event was that so this
there there's a a meme team it's called
the Dilly meme team and this guy in a
wheelchair showed up at a disantis event
wearing a Dilly mem Team hat and because
he didn't like his hat he got rolled out
of the and then there's the other guy
Matt Kim is that his name yeah he got
kicked out as well kicked out too these
guys didn't do anything they just showed
up and obviously they're critical of Dan
santis on the interweb and man I kind of
wish I went to those events I texted you
two photos from a from the caucus event
of of Nikki Haley voters and so you can
give people a sort of a an image of I I
have they we have a production team here
and they're
do can you tweet them I can't pull them
from my phone screen y if you tweet them
out yourself I'll pull up your Twitter
okay God bless you all all right man
thanks for hanging out I suppose if uh
whoever is waiting in the wings wants to
jump on while we're waiting for vake
unless he here you guys want to rock
paper scissors for it J's right here Bru
ladies and gentlemen Josie the redheaded
libertarian is jumping in how's it going
I'm gonna pull it Benny Johnson's
Twitter I'm tweeting it right now he's
tweeting it right now what's your
analysis uh Josie on everything yeah
you're sitting there watching grab that
mic talk to us I just want Nikki to lose
tonight amen well I think we're good I
think I think uh if anything is worth
celebrating it's her defeat and I and
look there is there is a funny thing
about watching Ronda Sanders lose to
Nikki Haley but I really want Nikki
Haley to come in forth I just want
everyone to be like yeah nobody wants
her get out of here is this because
people are genuinely concerned that
Trump will be taken off the ballot
somehow like are people do is that
actually like I mean it's not rhetorical
question but like is it what what do you
mean the threat that Trump will either
be removed legally no I know but what do
you think would like what would that
explain then the next runner up would be
the the the number one candidate the
front runner for the Republican ticket
Cassandra Fairbanks had another tweet
too we have these images that were
showing of these Nikki Haley voters and
it was a guy with a peace sign tattoo
voting for Nikki Haley and Cassandra uh
McDonald you know she she works here
she's great she was just like how are
you so dumb like Nikki Haley is the
warmonger candidate like what do you
think some own old Boomer Democrat with
a pece tattoo from their hippie days
yeah and now they're in the uh corporate
shill days I guess unfortunately yeah
but look you know if uh if if Nikki
loses which he's going to she there's no
way she's winning then uh we all have
reason to celebrate I guess but it is
what it is thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 P.M and become a member over at
timcast.net censored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time